Estados Unidos desembolsa cada año
cerca de 600.000 millones de dólares en
materia militar
Si hiciésemos una lista con los países
que más gastan en defensa todo el mundo
por supuesto que Estados Unidos estaría
en primer lugar pero es que además
gastaría más que los 11 siguiente
países juntos de la lista ¿qué barbaridad,
verdad? Dentro de este desorbitado
presupuesto podemos encontrar
equipamiento militar tan sofisticado y
poderoso como el bombardero B-2 Spirit,
diseñado en plena Guerra Fría con la
misión de arrasar la URSS en caso de
que fuera necesario y que costó a los
contribuyentes más de 77.000 millones
de dólares sin incluir el coste
operativo del avión que alcanza la
friolera de 150 mil dólares cada hora
de vuelo
También tenemos como ejemplo la clase Ford
de portaaviones el barco más caro
jamás construido que cuenta con dos
reactores nucleares y estará preparado
para albergar a los últimos cazas de
quinta generación según los planes del
gobierno
este proyecto tendría un coste total de
140.000 millones de dólares pero esto
no es nada comparado con el que se ha
convertido el proyecto militar más caro
de la historia del mundo el f-35 sólo
el coste de desarrollo ronda los 400.000
millones de dólares para que os hagáis
una idea con ese dinero podríamos ir
a la bolsa y hacernos con el control de
todas las empresas del ibex 35
de un plumazo
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a hablar
de este peculiar, el f-35 el
archienemigo del contribuyente americano.
"¿Cuándo se levantará el
ministro de defensa y responderá por el
fiasco del f-35? ¿Dónde está su
responsabilidad? Todo nace en 1996 cuando
el ejército de Estados Unidos decide
sacar a concurso la producción de un
avión polivalente capaz de hacer de todo
Es por eso por lo que el f-35
cuenta con tres versiones diferentes
por un lado tenemos el f-35 A, destinado
la fuerza aérea, pensado especialmente
para el combate aire-aire y que
sustituirá a los f-16 el que ha sido el
avión más exitoso en la historia de
los Estados Unidos con más de
4.500 unidades producidas. Por
otro lado tenemos al F-35 B, la
variante que posee la capacidad de
despegar y aterrizar verticalmente y que
sustituirá a los Harriers y a los F-18
Hornet el cuerpo de marines en tercer y
último lugar tenemos al f-35 C
la versión con alas de mayor tamaño y
plegables lo que le permite ser
embarcada y que sustituirá a los f-18
de la marina de los Estados Unidos
Pero desde que en el año 2001 la
multinacional americana Lockheed Martin
empezar a desarrollar este proyecto todo han
sido baches en el camino. Desde que se
adjudicó se han retrasado ya más de 15 años, algunos países
han llegado a cancelar los encargos que
tenían y el presupuesto se ha ido a más
del doble del inicial por otro lado el
Pentágono saca pecho de la capacidad de
camuflaje de este nuevo avión pero sin
embargo otros se atreven hasta a criticar las
capacidades técnicas y de combate que
éste súper avión podría llegar a tener.
"Le han
puesto unas alas ridículas que le
permiten despegar verticalmente pero que
le imposibilitan maniobrar en combate
necesitas salas para crear sustentación
sin alas no hay giros eso hace el avión
del todo imposible de maniobrar"
Pierre Sprey ha sido analista para el
Departamento de Defensa de los Estados
Unidos y codiseñador de aviones tan
exitosos como el F-16 o el A-10, por
lo tanto su opinión tiene algo de
valor. Pero vale, puede que no sea tipo más
imparcial es comentarista casi fijo de
RT y ya hemos visto en vídeos anteriores
que hay detrás de todo ello.
¿Pero alguien cuestionaría el compromiso y la
credibilidad de alguien como el senador
y candidato a la casa blanca por el
partido republicano John Mccain? John
Mccain es otro gran crítico de este
proyecto.
-"La trayectoria del
proyecto del F-35 ha sido tanto un
escándalo como una tragedia
en cuanto a coste calendario y
rendimiento"
Así es, John Mccain da
totalmente en el clavo. ¿Cómo ha podido una
compañía adjudicataria como Lockheed
llegar a donde ha llegado? El Pentágono
afirma que este proyecto es tan grande
que ya no tiene vuelta atrás ya no puede
fallar. Pero sin embargo yo me pregunto
cómo ha podido llegar esto a ser tan
grande como es sin que nadie haya puesto
ningún tipo de freno.
Los números son para quitar la
respiración de hecho lo son
literalmente hace un par de meses un
general de las fuerzas aéreas
encargado de los presupuestos se
desmayó mientras estaba dando una rueda
de prensa sobre el f-35.
-"Esto es lo que te hará el f-35"
¿Pero qué ha pasado con todo ese dinero?
¿A dónde se ha ido? ¿Os acordáis de la
empresa adjudicataria de este proyecto,
Lockheed Martin, de la que hemos hablado
antes?
Bueno pues parece que a sus propietarios
no les ha ido nada mal,
de hecho les ha ido genial. Desde que
todo esto empezara en 2001 la empresa ha
multiplicado su valor por seis.
De hecho si miramos las cotizaciones de
esta empresa en bolsa
veremos que sus propietarios habrían
obtenido una rentabilidad del 542% en
tan sólo una década. Para que os hagáis una idea en el mismo tramo de tiempo
el S&P 500 ha rendido un 70%.
"¿Qué narices pasa con esta empresa de
armamento que lleva 52 semanas subiendo
en la bolsa en este mercado con todos
los recortes del presupuesto de defensa?"
Pero esto no acaba aquí muchas de las
piezas del f-35 se subcontratan a
empresas como Amphenol. Pues bien, en este
caso sus propietarios no habrían multiplicado por
seis su valor en bolsa lo habrían
multiplicado por diez.
"Lockheed Martin, nunca olvidamos para
quien trabajamos"
¿Lo mejor de todo? Que el
negocio no acaba más que empezar y es
que se estima que para cuando este programa
termina, que tiene 55 años de vida, los
contribuyentes habrán desembolsado un
total de un billón y medio de dólares
¿pero es esto realista? El último F-35
será entregado en 2040 no comprendo
cómo esta estrategia tiene sentido
comprar un avión de combate con un
diseño de 40 años de antigüedad con
todo lo que este comité ha sabido sobre
cómo nuestros potenciales adversarios
están rápidamente alcanzándonos y en
algunos casos igualando las ventajas
tecnológicas militares americanas"
Si os digo la verdad para mí esto es una gran
estafa, una gran estafa producto de una
vez más del capitalismo de amiguetes
¿Acaso podemos meter bajo el manto de la
seguridad todo tipo de cosas sin
límites y sin control?
Espero que os haya gustado este vídeo, si
tienes cualquier comentario no dudéis en
hacerlo y nos vemos el próximo video.
¡un saludo! En VisualPolitik estamos a
punto de alcanzar los mil suscriptores y
queremos celebrarlo de una forma muy
especial con todos vosotros como
últimamente no hacen más que salir
noticias sobre los Panama Papers
hemos pensado que podrímos hacer un
vídeo respondiendo a todas las dudas
que podáis tener sobre la evasión
fiscal.
Cualquier pregunta que tengáis
nos la podéis enviar a través de
nuestra página de facebook o
mandándolos un mensaje privado al canal
de YouTube. ¡Esperamos vuestros mensajes!